hi mystery Recaps here today I'm going
to explain an American Science Fiction
action film called pray spoilers ahead
watch out and take care
the movie is set in the Northern Great
Plains during the early 18th century
this is the period when European
settlers had already colonized most
parts of the country they looted the
resources killed the Local Natives and
destroyed the forests to build cities at
the start we see a young Comanche girl
Naru who enjoys hunting she is a
well-trained dog named sari who appears
to be extremely loyal to her one morning
in the forest Naru is practicing with
her ax when she notices a deer she
decides to hunt it down but a loud
Thunderclap causes the deer to flee not
willing to give up Naru and her dog
pursue the deer with all their might but
still they are unsuccessful in capturing
it during the process sari's tale
becomes entangled in a bear trap causing
him extreme pain luckily Naru quickly
comes to his rescue once she frees sari
from the trap she also applies some
natural remedies to his tail let me just
rub some berries on that [__] there
after this the two prepare to return
home but just then they hear a loud
noise coming from the sky Naru
immediately goes to investigate and when
she reaches a nearby Cliff she sees a
large alien ship flying through the
clouds must have accidentally inhaled
some of those berries in the following
scene Naru meets her brother tabe who is
an excellent hunter in fact he is
regarded as the fiercest fighter in the
entire tribe whenever they go for a big
Hunt tabe is the one who leads them Naru
shares with him that she saw a
Thunderbird in the sky earlier she also
expresses that she is ready to join him
in the upcoming hunt however tabe does
not believe that she is prepared saying
it is dangerous following this Naru
returns to her mother and assists her in
preparing some medicine as she is
sharpening her ax her mother inquires as
to why she wants to Hunt Naru responds
that she is as skilled as the others
because she uses her intelligence more
than her physicality however even her
mother believes that she can't hunt this
proves that the kamachi people do not
think that their women are capable of
hunting like their male counterparts a
few moments later tabe arrives with a
hunted bird for food but Naru does not
appear to be pleased with it on the
other hand a dangerous looking Predator
jumps out of the ship he has extremely
Advanced weapons on him like lasers
thermal vision and also the ability to
become invisible to give us a brief demo
of his abilities the Predator walks into
the forest and effortlessly kills a
giant snake elsewhere while Gathering
herbs for the medicines Naru notices the
man making their way into the jungle in
order to kill a lion when she learns
that the lion has captured one of their
men named Pui she decides to join them
as expected the men refused to let her
come along but when tabe vouches that
she can help treat the wounded they
agree soon the search begins and anaru
guides everyone using her so-called
intelligent brain they wander around for
hours and ultimately find Pui who is in
a brutal condition Naru immediately
provides him with medications and herbs
saving his life after the successful
Rescue Mission everyone prepares to to
leave but tabi is adamant on Hunting the
feral lion down so he instructs the
other men to carry puhi back to their
Camp while he goes after the lion
however Naru is somewhat skeptical
because Lions normally finish off their
prey instantly they do not just leave
them to suffer so she asks to join him
but tabe declines on the way back Naru
discovers the dead and gutted snake as
well as the Predator's footprint the
other men believe that the footprint is
that of a large bear but Naru is
confused as she has never seen one this
size before hence she decides to go back
to tabe and warn him about the same a
member of their Camp named Paka also
joins her soon after she meets tabe and
tells him everything but he too believes
it was a bear following this the three
of them set out to hunt the lion Naru
suggests placing bait and taking a
position on a tree to effectively attack
the lion after a while she along with
Paka climbs a tree while tabe places the
bait and hides behind some bushes the
plan works and the lion arrives on the
scene but but instead of going after the
bait it lunges towards the duo at first
the lion kills Paka and slowly starts
moving towards Naru the latter is
holding a spear confident that she can
defend herself but right then she
notices the Predator this distracts her
momentarily allowing the lion enough
time to strike her and knock her to the
ground a few hours later Naru wakes up
and finds herself back at the Village
Camp it turns out that her brother saved
her from The Lion and brought her home
meanwhile tabe also arrives with the
lion's head all the villagers are proud
of him so the elders Elevate him to the
position of war chief however naaru
remains convinced that there is
something else in the forest and wishes
to go back she tells tabe about it but
the latter dismisses her stating that
she is not prepared to hunt yet since no
one believes her Naru decides to take
matters into her own hands early the
next morning she along with her dog
heads to the forest to investigate there
she makes a rope out of woodskins ties
it to to her ax and uses it as a
boomerang with the help of it she is
able to hunt down a rabbit which she
cooks in the forest and eats with sorry
meanwhile the Predator is watching a
wolf which is about to pounce on a small
animal as soon as the wolf catches its
prey the Predator attacks and kills it
invisible 3D Slice on the other hand
Naru continues to move in search of
clues about the predator and after a
while she arrives at a location where
she discovers several dead buffalo with
their skins ripped off Naru is shocked
and perplexed as to who could have done
this as buffaloes are regarded as
symbols of honor and generosity in their
culture alongside the bodies she
discovers a cigar but Naru is unaware of
what it is after her investigation is
done she continues her journey until she
falls into a swamp to make matters worse
it turns out to be quicksand Naru slowly
drowns inside and it appears as if she
will suffocate to death but fortunately
she still has her ax Boomerang using
this she somehow manages to rest skew
herself Naru then heads to the nearby
River to clean herself up meanwhile we
see the Predator noticing the same cigar
in the next scene Naro discovers a large
bear devouring its prey normally even
the bravest of villagers would run away
from the beast but Naru has a point to
prove she wants to kill it and take its
head to the Village as a trophy
unfortunately at the last second her bow
breaks and the bear notices her now with
the tables turned Naru runs for her life
and eventually hides beneath a beaver
dam however the bear using his
incredible sense of smell tracks her
down it is about to devour her when
suddenly the Predator arrives at the
scene and attacks it the two beasts then
get into a fight but the bear is
eliminated within seconds witnessing
this Naru is taken aback and she
immediately swims away to save herself
the Predator notices her but doesn't
react believing she is no threat to him
even the invisible aliens are sexist
following this Naru arrives at the shore
where she is approached by cement from
her Village it turns out that after she
went missing tabe directed his men to
look for her Naru frantically explains
to them about what she saw but no one
believes her instead they asked her to
return to the camp Monaro refuses they
apprehend her and tire up meanwhile the
Predator appears to be watching them
from nearby using his advanced
technology he has marked their weapons
shortly after the tribe's men hear the
Predators Roar and notice some movement
in the bushes scared they take up their
positions and one of them fires an arrow
into the bush then he slowly moves
forward to investigate only to discover
that it is just a rabbit this cracks up
all the men and they make fun of naru's
fear but just then three lasers point at
the man's body followed by metal arrows
killing him instantly because of this
the other men start shooting their
arrows in random directions and one of
them hits the predator and exposes his
real self the men immediately begin
attacking him but the deadly alien is so
powerful that he effort oh God I gotta
chill but the deadly alien is so
powerful that he effortlessly kills the
man one after another The Kills are
sweet too bad you can't see them because
if YouTube's stupid guidelines as the
fight goes on narios somehow frees
herself and escapes from the area
unfortunately the Predator kills all the
men and starts pursuing her Naru tries
to lose him in the woods but ends up
getting caught in a bear trap soon the
Predator approaches her seemingly to
finish her off however seeing her
struggling and in pain he stops this
makes Naru realize that the Predator
does not attack bait or unarmed ones at
the same time some French Hunters arrive
with guns knock Naru out and kidnap her
in the next scene she regains
Consciousness and finds herself trapped
inside a wooden cage she then notices a
man smoking a cigar and learns that he
is the one who killed the Buffalo
earlier just then a translator
approaches her and asks what she knows
about the Predator when Naru does not
respond they reveal another hostage who
is none other than tabe Naru is taken
aback to see him there but she can do
nothing about it shortly after the
siblings are taken into the forest where
they are tied up as bait for the
invisible alien to hunt tabe panics but
Naru assures him that the Predator does
not attack defenseless beings
unsurprisingly the same thing happens
the Predator slowly approaches the men
from behind and starts killing them one
by one these kills are even sweeter too
bad you still can't see them because of
YouTube's stupid guidelines while the
massacre continues the siblings manage
to free themselves tabe goes to find a
horse for himself while Naru goes to the
French Hunter's camp where her dog's
sorry is being held on reaching it she
wipes out the remaining Hunters using
her impressive moves but before she
leaves with her dog the translator
approaches her his leg has been severed
so he begs for medication in exchange
she offers to teach her how to use a gun
Naru agrees and gives him some medicine
that lowers his body temperature as she
is learning how to use the gun they hear
the Predator's scary Roar it sounds like
this
anyway
so Naru immediately hides behind a tree
while the translator pretends to be dead
surprisingly the Predator isn't able to
locate the translator because of his low
body temperature this makes Naru realize
that he has a weakness after all but the
Predator makes up for this rare weakness
with his intelligence he steps on all
the corpses one by one most of them do
not respond but when it's the
translator's turn he screams in pain
realizing that the human was only
pretending to be dead the Predator kills
him in a Flash after this he spots sari
and deems his laser at it however as he
is about to shoot tabe arrives out of
nowhere and attacks the Predator's head
causing his helmet to fall off as a
result the laser present in the helmet
points and shoots the tree rather than
sorry seeing this Naru realizes that the
metal arrow is following the laser
points rather than the enemy's location
by the time the Predator retrieves his
helmet tabe attacks him surprisingly the
tribesman goes toe-to-toe with him and
even manage just to land some impressive
shots this annoys the Predator so he
finally becomes invisible a few seconds
later he catches tabe off guard and
stabs him from behind killing him
mercilessly Naru watches this unfold
right before her eyes but she doesn't
have time to mourn she flees with her
dog immediately the next morning she
spots one of the surviving French
Hunters across the river and apprehends
him she severs his leg preventing him
from fleeing and using him as bait she
then takes the medication which lowers
her body temperature and makes it
impossible for the Predator to censor a
while later the Predator arrives as
planned and tries to go after the person
who set up the bait but as expected he
is unable to locate Naru suddenly she
shoots him in the head from behind takes
his helmet and runs away following this
she positions the helmet in such a way
that the laser can be directed at the
Predator soon he arrives and Naru jumps
onto him and begins tussling she manages
to cut off his hand using his own own
weapon next she along with the help of
sorry ties the Predator with a rope and
drags him to the swamp as per the plan
he points the metal arrows at Naru
oblivious to the fact that the laser is
aimed at himself when he shoots the
metal arrows end up penetrating his own
head finally killing him in the last
scene Naru returns to her village with
the Predator's head making everyone
proud of her look everybody Naru killed
a fish or what what the hell is that she
is then declared as the new Warchief
something which she has always dreamed
of subscribe for more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching